I am welcome to this video now I
Yardbird yahoo okay so how do we get we
get the bogo it's not the kind of person
to play any london system or whatever
let's see what is coming up with him the
Queen e7 bogo not a line that I look at
in mine my book project it's very
interesting though that's an interesting
line for black with rook da TM possible
maybe 95 is the absolute main move and I
think the only one that really puts some
serious question and okay it's not doing
it i have e 5 as the first good yeah
c'mon let's not let's try to not far so
far behind him I mean this is really a
good opening result already see probably
can he sacrifice the Queen that's what
I'm getting at because well he is close
to those measures now as the d5 corn is
very very vulnerable stuff like afore
can already be really good for black and
I come on I don't know that's probably
more than one good continuation now
he's in the D file and I have Bishop g4
coming when the night moves Bishop g4
and then night night before so I went d
phi faults this seems very very
problematic for bladder for YTM visual
g4 was another interesting move but i
wasn't sure if he may be can maybe he
can even sacrifice the Queen and c6 yeah
I expected that normal continuations
weren't already very very bad for him so
he wants to stay up trouble there is
some point to that the knight on c3 is
very stable mile structures not good but
all in all this is some can can only be
and this is a purely defensive from
sacrifice of the Queen so h 6o g 6 a g6
problem for King g7 let's see rook d6
maybe I want I want activity mm6 ma'am
it's not so easy to to find a way
forward you can put the Queen on before
yeah difficult difficult to make any
headway Queen B form is the only way
basically it's I'm going for for that
short autumn mmm what to do a 54 ms go
is going a 3 can try to put the bishop
on d3 thats it's probably an IDM and
pawn to you for yeah maybe he needed to
do it but it's nothing that he he loves
to claim well I could have taken d2 or
kind of pre move was that ah ah yes
great great great great wow that that
was very easy right he really keeps
going forward in this position I really
wonder this is not really helping him I
think
hmm ok so before I have it this this is
now somewhat loose yeah this is king
position check for Queen age three
we are taking on d to was some quite
quite a bit easier
yeah store should be this should be good
right look H 2 23 wins g3s is really
difficult to defend unless you play that
one and can I take on g3 now Queen takes
King of one queen king tags and Clint x
f4 chick Kincannon over good sorry so
this isn't directly winning a pawn
check I hope that I'm not hey then I'm
not fire I'm gonna handle I'm not on
some suicide mission here kingi form but
the only has the one check ride and i'm
going to h three I don't see how I can
do it with without the king probably I
really need the King to to win this
that's not even leading to very much
time morning I can take a photo but
nothing more right don't see anything
better so okay check I go back
g4 check I'm going ahead King a fork if
it's not a maid right ok let's go
forward 34 seconds
I cannot calculate I hope I'm not
running into some stupid chick medium
check check ig5 is really a maid
unbelievable that stuff is chell
threatening made one check check check I
cannot try for down here again whoo
seven seconds yeah well probably winning
some Howard I have seven seconds yeah
are always some some swindling things
here with the kicker on age three and
Jim yeah of course I should win this
this game it was some pretty much pretty
pretty clear fair I was winning out of
the opening with the Queen I mean
winning is maybe too strong but he can
struggle but white why does this is
definitely I mean okay this is you know
I just just stupid yeah i was thinking
how i can take and i do the pre movement
if you just for a moment he not pre-move
yeah you see that the rookies hanging
okay in the opening this is already a
very problematic for white after you
form if he is not sacrificing I mean he
has really no good move if he goes to g5
for example I have a have a nice choice
I wanted to go Bishop g4 computer now
points out this move which is also very
neat this is this is very nice like it's
some almost winning him very nice yeah I
wanted to play this actually it wasn't
really sure what what White's reply errs
yeah the computer wants to give the
exchange yeah wyd loses material it mean
if he moves the rook it just went there
so this is starting move do you want to
play then again this is this is much
stronger even and why does in this pin
so Bishop here but should be six and
append and old I am remarkable yeah the
opening really went excellently and now
yeah maybe can I do something better
than this but it looks very normal
activating rupee age you can argue about
that yeah the thing is that wide
structure is very it's very solid if he
just stays and does nothing I'm not
quite sure what I'm doing I mean he
didn't really stay he went forward with
stuff which this kind of his his nature
but it looked wrong to me that only
gives me some some ideas I mean playing
for a win for widest completely it's not
realistic at all you have no winning
chances here even if I'm doing really
stupid stuff you won't you won't win
chan yeah and bye-bye now here this is
just just winning for black but maybe
not yeah even here if he stays and does
nothing it's difficult for for me to
make headway check so I counted I could
enter and sent here well Cheryl you
should win but uncheck it is it is
tricky business with with maids I could
take me to hear okay well I this was
pretty clear check and then this check
okay yeah well i was i was somewhat down
on time at oil yet here it was okay
actually yeah well there were many many
chances to win okay thanks for watching